morning everyone um Welcome to our new
palacial home for the day the ballroom
is open um representative Pearson would
you lead us in the pledge
please
thank you very
much glad no one lit the fireplace
um want to thank our substitutes for the
day um representative uh
Edgar um it's Edgar or correct right
yeah um representative McGee and
representative M thank
you oh and representative n on our side
um you're around the corner it's a
little hard
to see around the corner for me um we're
going to take some things out of order
so that uh people can get back to work
um so I think first thing I will do is
call the exact session on House Bill
1479 and I
would um recognize representative Sheen
no mcarter for a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion of a to pass
representative mcarter moves ought to
pass on House Bill
1479 uh is there a second
seconded by representative sers the bill
is open for further Amendment
uh representative mcarter would you like
to
move an
amendment yes I
would yeah yes I'd like to um move the
amendment that's in front of us right
now um to hb1
1479 I guess the number would be good uh
what is it
20240 92
82h how about uh
20249 82h how about it excellent good
choice
um that's the motion
um is there a second second and by
sellers um we'll have discussion on uh
this amendment
and I think it would be best if I
handled
that um since my name is on the top of
it so um we had a couple of
issues with the bill as written um that
I'm sure
everybody we've had this conversation
before um so this amendment solves two
or three of those problems that the
original Bill language had um
the original language uh required towns
to find a different funding source um
Beyond any taxpayer funds
um and uh and it was set up so that um
if you are going to have any of the
services you are going to have to pay
for those not only with State funds uh
not with State funds as the existing law
States but also without local locally
raised funds so uh that was one issue um
the amendment speaks to that um it also
created a penalty for um non- compliance
and I think the committee as a whole I
think I'm fair in saying that the
committee as a whole found that
problematic in that it seemed that it
would be unenforceable and if nothing
else would need a whole lot more
definition of how that would be
enforced um so this amendment does two
things um because we
recognized um the concern of a large
number of our constituents and I have as
maybe you have as well received um quite
a lot of mail from around the state um
it seems to me that there are two things
that uh that we needed to do um one was
um for
those um lobbying firms that offered
multiple
Services um give the ability for a an
individual member town city um or
organization to be able to um
designate whether um they wanted
lobbying services or not um and leave it
up to them the town so that's one thing
that this amendment does is is create
the choice um for a town to decide
whether they want lobbying or not um to
do that it requires that the lobbying
Services create a
um I'll call it an alart menu but um
that's only for purposes of uh the
discussion not for in the in the
paperwork itself but a um an individ
idiz Services um cost sheet um where
individual towns um would be able to um
pick which services that they wanted um
and in that uh if they chose not to have
lobbying services for their town they
would be Exempted from um 155 RSA 155
which is the requirement to segregate
State funds currently
it's a little disturbing to me just as a
side note here how
many how many people are not aware of um
155 and that requirement to segregate
State funds not just as a bookkeeping
entry but as physically SE separate
those
funds it's a um little disturbing in
that uh it would seem to me that some of
these lobbying firms should be making
having their clients aware of that
requirement that's state law um so
that's uh the
primary purpose of the amendment um it
does as I said U eliminate
the the uh penalty phase of the original
language it also requires um the
lobbying firms to provide uh notice um
informing them of that requirement under
155 to segregate for State funds um they
are um required to get a a signature
from the member to um that they
understand and acknowledge that uh that
155 um exists and that would get filed
um with the regularly U scheduled
lobbyist uh filings with the secretary
of
state right now it's that's set up is
quarterly
um in the future I think there's
legislation going through now into the
Senate that would make that three times
a year um it may be something we want to
look at in the future of just making
that filing once a year um that that a
member would would just be uh um
agreeing or acknowledging that 155 and
the requirement to segregate funds um
exists only once a
year um but the big thing here
uh there's one other thing it also would
allow in the in this amendment for any
city or town that opts out of um
lobbying to be Exempted from U 155
requirements I think I mentioned that
but I wanted to make sure that that's
clear so really it's doing three major
things
um but what the takeaway here is that um
cities and towns we've heard from our
constituents that cities and towns
um value the services that they're
getting from these organizations that
offer other services to lobbying um but
they've never had the opportunity to do
anything except buy all of it or buy
none of it and um and so this would give
them the opportunity to um to decide
what fits best with their community and
fund that
appropriately um so I think I think with
that um you've got the whole Amendment
um in your hands so if it's something
that we want to entertain discussion I'm
happy to uh ask yep thank you very much
Mr chairman and thank all of you for
working on this um I'm still trying to
grasp this so bear with me please um in
the original Bill uh we see on lines 10
and 11 uh mere bookkeeping separation of
the public funds from other monies shall
not be sufficient so that takes care of
some of what you're talking about um how
how are we achieving this
um without bookkeeping I'm a little bit
lost please help me sure so what you
read um about that's existing law um the
the mere bookkeeping um and the segre
ation of funds is is existing law for
State funds right that would remain true
under this amendment as well um the only
difference would be is if an a city or
town chose not to have lobbying they
would be exempt from that requirement to
segregate the state funds because
they're not purchasing lobbying Services
okay thank you
yep representative McGee yes I'm clearly
coming late to the party but I did have
a question I noticed that the bill in
its original form is an FN and my
question is around the effects that it
will have on um the economics of the
situation um in terms of you know
lobbying groups that currently sort of
benefit towns and that sort of thing
like the municipal Association um does
this is this intended to have little or
no effect on their organization and
their finances or um have do we have any
kind of breakdown in terms of the fiscal
note as to what kind of an economic
impact it would have um with towns and
the
state it's just I'm just I'm sorry if
I'm taking us to someplace that the
committee's already been but I just was
really curious no I don't think the
committee has been in that direction um
it was it was my my understanding that
the fiscal note was um in the original
Bill primarily for the um the penalty
phase of of this not not for anything
else so I would assume um that when
we adopt the amendment the fiscal note
um would either go away Andor if the
speaker refers it to finance they will
um they will
wave that's that's my
understanding thank you sure further
questions
comments representative Pearson thank
you Mr chair I just as a someone who has
a as a general rule likes local
control I like the idea that this pretty
much brings it down to the local level
and makes that decision making at a
local level so that this is something
that I can easily support uh especially
with that now being where the decision-
making comes from thank you
representative
Pearson further
comments I'm
assuming that um Democrats would like to
us on it and and discuss given that
both of us have just received this in
the last um whatever half hour
um but it is
um I'd be looking for
um it be looking for any kind of um
typographical or or errors that you if
we could separate for about 10 minutes
if that's um so why don't why don't we
say we're back here at
10:30 is that
enough
good all right we're in recess until
10:30 what
can
well the Democrats of caucus and there's
a consensus the Democrats we're back in
ex session thank you Mr chairman the
Democrats of caucus and there's a
consensus among the members as to what
position to take on this and we are
there further
questions yes so uh Mr chair I know that
in my emails you mentioned the the large
response and we had a a good um number
of people coming in and speaking to us
on this bill um uh and on the original
Bill the original Bill and then correct
um and then just getting this amendment
today though but for smaller towns it's
been hearing from them that this the
original bill could be very difficult
for them can you make also report for
the committee the blue the number on the
blue sheets from that um uh original
Bill too because I think that the
response is is is not for this bill but
do you have that number I think it was
very close I thought um on the well I
may be thinking of the online testimony
and that number I thought was with when
within one or two I don't remember do
you have that as the clerk I thought
that was something that as committee
members we can always have that data and
information uh we can we will we'll get
it for you okay should we pause and wait
for that or
uh well let me let me ask a different
question so if the number was um 24 54
either way does that do for us I think
for me I want to make sure I'm I'm
responsive to the public and the
constituents on this that's first and
foremost um so I want to and I want to
kind of be sure that I have a actual
number um versus each of our memories
but that is um I I just want to um make
clear the numbers that we will dig out
are for the original Bill not what we're
talking about here correct and there but
we're still moving through the process
of a bill we're working to potentially
make as you stated amendments can make a
bill better but in lack of having a lot
of time we're still voting on some of
those premises so I'm still none of
those premises this this repes all all
of them okay okay I appreciate that so I
guess what I'm trying to put forth is
the numbers that you're looking for
don't reflect what this amendment does
on the amendment because we haven't had
a chance okay so I appreciate that and
that um I think further solidifies
because we need to make sure that we
have an opportunity you know for that
public too yeah and being able we're
listening to the amendment we're
effectively replacing an entire bill
that the public then has not had a
chance to weigh in on in the same way
correct would you well which is which is
true which is what happens correct I
just but that I just there will be
another question I asked in in caucus
what are our numbers so that's and
usually it's something that you've
reported before so I thought it was
something simple and easy for you to
have um the only number that I can tell
you and I can pull it off um online the
on online testimony I didn't I'm quite
certain I never have even looked at the
the blue sheet quote unquote the one
that was from the hearing day um but not
something that you looked at okay yeah
and I wouldn't U I don't want to spend
us to go much but again for me it's moot
at this point because it's that was
reflective of the original Bill not the
amended Bill
turn further discussion questions
oh rep sellers yeah thank you Mr chair
so Mr chair if if I understand the
amendment
uh it's really allowing more flexibility
and more local
control over lobbying or what can and
cannot be lob is that is that my
understanding um I think absolutely um
there's nothing in this amendment that
replaces the entire bill there's nothing
in this amendment that
removes any option that a city or town
had previously or has currently I guess
is a better way of saying um all this
does is provide another option that's it
so nothing is being removed if that's
your question yeah yeah thank you and
and one followup sure and and and it it
also on the original Bill we had
penalties which those are gone correct
so we're not penalti anything right
correct thank
you representative nting
Wong hello
um so I was reading through this and
currently if you don't like if your town
doesn't want to join something or you
don't have to join an organization that
provides lobbying and non-
lobbying um services at the moment
correct and correct and and now as well
they don't have to either yeah but this
would um nothing's changed with that
yeah um but in this bill
um we would be charging those
organizations to separate
between their lob to separate their
lobbying and non-
lobbying arms I
guess um would it can you ask it a
different way yeah I'm trying to figure
out where I read
it okay so in line it says shall
establish an independent Services fee
schedule for non- lobbying lobbying
services so they would be separate in
that
way and they would only have to pay for
the services they want the alicart menu
we've spoken up before um but already if
you don't like what they're doing you
just don't have to join correct correct
you don't have yeah just like now um if
if your Town's people uh decide not to
put a money in a line item for any
particular organization or
service you vote it out this is this is
not
clearly this is different than what the
original bill was which
required um it was it was authoritarian
it was the state telling you telling the
town what you can spend your money on
and that was the problem that many of us
had um
you know I don't I don't feel it's our
job to tell a town what they can spend
their money on this is providing that
same ability for the well someone said
local control you decide what you want
to spend your money on not
us this is this is letting them if they
decide not to be members of the clerk's
Association have at it go ahead um
you're spending your own money the only
thing that we're retaining here is what
state money and it's exactly the same as
what's now what state money can be spent
on that's the only restriction and
that's what exists in current law we
haven't touched that at
all okay um so to me it feels like in
the name of local control we are then um
telling organizations how they can and
cannot
work um we are telling
organizations
how um how their members can access
their
services okay that makes more sense to
me which which which we do again
routinely um if if you want to have
access or or Lobby here here are the
rules for how we do that and and that
section is full of those kind of things
this is how you know you will provide
quarterly statements yeah same thing no
different so we are this amendment does
nothing to the existing
relationship if if an organization if a
town city or town or um if they
decide to operate exactly as they are
now nothing changes except for one thing
they now have to acknowledge that 155
exists
that's the only
difference and then and then there is an
additional option for them there's there
we're not nothing in this amendment
takes anything away from how they
operate now if they want
to
representative H uh thank you Mr chair
um yeah I view this um this amendment
very much as a compromise because for me
on the
principle um I agreed with the
underlying bill but there was real
complications with the underlying bill
as you had said because what it's
essentially doing is forcing you know
the the prohibition of lobbying on the
state and what this does is it doesn't
change if no if a town doesn't want
anything to change and their select
board wants nothing to change nothing
changes the only associations that um
this would affect would be the ones that
don't have the allart services but M but
require lobbying to be a part of the
association and I've heard from several
people that um they don't know how how
like a town vote would go it's very
possible that no the vote would still
value those lobbying Services over
everything else um but but they value
the other services and don't want the
lobbying and they can't separate that
out currently it is all or nothing on
the association and all this does is Al
allows that uh separation if say you
wanted legal services but not lobbying
services to take out the lobbying
services and then you don't even have to
segregate your funds then if you're not
using so it's a um it's even easier to
comply and it's not exactly what I
wanted okay because um I don't like
taxpayer uh funded lobbying uh it still
allows that um the what this does again
is it gives a choice to me choices this
can go um where literally no Town
votes if at all you know we we don't
know how many people in our town uh
would would want to separate that out
and if they do separate it out you still
get which we heard here in public
testimony that most of what um a lot of
these associations do first of all is
great work but they also say and we
don't know I I haven't seen the numbers
but they say 90% of what they do is
provide information is not lobbying it's
only about 10% of their efforts and if
that's the case then then even if um
many towns like chose to not Lobby it
shouldn't really even affect those
associations that much um if truly what
they're doing is 90% of the information
because you know and then also as as um
select boards and and moderators and
town clerks are already exempt from all
of the lobbying um uh under under this
law under current law um nothing
prevents them from pulling out that
lobbying saving that money and lobbying
you know sending emails directly to us
which we get sometimes anyway um so that
that's just my two cents I um I don't
love this um amendment I I viewed it as
a compromise to um try and try and give
a little bit of transparency on what
what is spent on lobbying with taxpayer
money and and the ability for individual
towns to vote just on the lobby portion
of of it and only on the associations
that mandate it on it's all or nothing
and that's the problem that I had with
it but um that's all I have Mr
chair thank you um further questions fur
the
discussion rep McGee thank you Mr
chairman um I just the only thought that
I had is that you know um we often times
deal with how things are done in New
Hampshire with the different
perspectives you know in terms of good
and bad and lobbying in in the case of
lobbying
uh for taxpayers in the state you know I
think there's a real value to the fact
that there's expertise and
effort you know spent in order to bring
those views to uh the lawmakers here so
that we have uh the information about
how we're impacting people on the front
line so when we talk about taking
taxpayer money for lobbyists those
lobbyists are also working in order to
make sure that tax impacts are lower
that's the whole point of that
particular uh type of lobbying so it's
not as though we're we're supplementing
through taxpayer money lobbyists that
are working on the on behalf of profit
making entities or others you know so I
I think we should not put it all in the
same bucket because lobbying is kind of
how we learn up here right people bring
us information that we might not
otherwise have about uh aspects of what
we're making decisions on as far as laws
so I just wanted to make that point um
because it lobbying isn't a bad word as
far as Government goes because we don't
have all the
answers thank you um my question
is um how does anything that you've just
said
change if if this if the taxpayers agree
with with what you've just said which I
think the bulk of them
would what changes as a result of
this well I I look at it as a a chipping
away of um how we are currently doing
local control um I know just from
sitting in school meetings um how there
are some folks who don't want to pay for
any public services and there's a
benefit to having a public service
that's spread over all of towns um and
so I think the economics for some of the
lobbyists that actually um Advocate on
behalf of
taxpayers um I think that the economics
for those organizations could very well
change and I think that's where the
concern is um because if it's if we're
making more hurdles for those folks in
terms of uh compliance and um
bookkeeping and and you know compliance
that kind of thing uh there may be more
expenses for them uh to spread out over
whatever towns are paying right so then
as people fall off it's just sort of a
weakening of the system that we have so
that's how I see it anyway y
representative
Shen yeah that just raised a question in
my mind um the forms that lobbyists have
to fill out right now don't they have to
um separate like um declare how much
money
um yes they do um I think it's Roman
five it's uh 15 156 understatements
Roman 5 subsection D so that wouldn't
make any um more work for them this this
amendment right because they're already
doing it they are already doing it um
the only the only slight additional work
for them is um this new statement that
for just those clients that ask for
lobbying
Services um they would be required to um
file a a signed form from the client
that says they understand the
restrictions on state funds being used
for purchasing lobbying that's the only
additional
paperwork further
comments representative W thank you Mr
chairman um we've heard from the
municipal Association that it would be
too difficult to break out the lobbying
fees from the general amount that is
given to them for membership
because membership to the municipal
Association based on population for my
community
so of course it's not up for us to
figure out how they're going to separate
that but I am curious how would they how
could they
separate what they use now for a common
formula for all communities in the state
how do they separate the lobbying part
from that do I have no
idea um as a financial adviser I will
tell you what I would do what I would
start with um as repan just mentioned um
these forms are filed uh Cally now that
indicate what portion of of their bill
to each Community is is broken down by
what category and how much it's it's
already there for uh for lobbying for
instance how much um is designated for
that they have to do that now so if it
were me I would go back and looked at
how I have um filled those forms out for
the
last however long I don't know Hampton
has been a client and said Gee here's
how I filled it out before here's here's
what I would start with what I'm going
to charge um next year and and I'll
Grant you um I forget who brought it up
but but someone did point out that in
testimony that they have no idea um what
bills representative Mass Millo is is
filing so they don't know how much time
they're going to be spending here on a
given
year but goodness um you if you've had a
client for 20 years um and you can see
you've been filling out those forms for
all those
years I got to believe there may be
anomaly years in there but I would think
you could come pretty darn close to what
that cost is um that's how I would do it
um whether that's it's not up to me to
to decide how how they would determine
that fee um we're we're careful not to
create that that number um but it's
certainly up to the the taxpayer to or
the selectman or who's ever purchasing
that service to ask how did they arrange
at that fee for that Community I would
think so it's not an All or Nothing
thing when you buy in for membership you
can buy in for specific sort of like
when you buy car insurance you know
suddenly you want to up the amount that
you would pay somebody if you killed
them or something like that um I don't
know why you went there but but you can
op in you can opt for a higher that's
really not how I buy car insurance but
when you buy car insurance you can opt
in for certain provisions and so that's
what you're saying here okay and what
you like may be different than what
McGee likes you know that's that's the
point I would keep coming back to the
idea that if you're happy with how if
you're happy with how it works
now that's still an option for you um
we're not we're not dictating we're not
taking anything away we are only giving
another option for the community to um
decide and and again
what with all do respect to R McGee she
may not be representative of everyone in
her community or she may be and they and
and whoever wins the day would be able
to follow their path whatever they want
to do um this doesn't this is enabling
this is not restrictive
language further discussion
comments rep sers thank you Mr chair so
I'm just making sure I have it 100%
right myself this bill
is technically all in the lobbyist it's
all about the lobbyist itself first of
all the second part of that is the bill
allows the
towns to pay for only the services that
they want at this point so they can
break it out so I mean if I had a uh a
pregnancy center let's say for the
school that came in that was a lobbyist
right they're a
lobbyist well maybe the Pregnancy Center
offers pro-life stuff which I'm against
or I'm for one or the other but the
point is is they they're also offering
Services counseling and and meds and and
other things which I want so you're
saying at that point the school can
actually pay for those part of the
services but not pay for the lobbyist is
that what I'm understanding uh I believe
that's absolutely correct and I think if
I heard one thing
from um the communities that or the
officials from the communities as I read
each one of the online
testimonies um they did point out many
of the things that
they that they currently receive as in
their membership that they want and this
is why they pay for the membership of
that
organization
um but again it's an all or nothing um
this is
merely giving that local community the
option or those local officials that
option of deciding whether um All or
Nothing fits them best or um some piece
of that fits them best that's all it
does thank you thank
you no further
discussion are we ready you you need
more time do you need more Consulting
time do you need I I'm I'm happy to do
we we have the room yes all
right um right at 11 o'clock we good
thanks
okay we're back um further
discussion seeing none motion on the
floor is all to pass as
amended and uh this is just the
amendment we're voting on right now um I
would ask the clerk to call the rooll
okay on Amendment
0982 H uh representative Vice chair
Sheen yes representative
costable the clerk votes yes
representative pi yes representative
mcarter yes representative na yes
representative sers yes representative
wall representative nutting Wong no
Representative turot no representative
Richards no representative McGee no
representative mam Millow sorry it's
okay
no uh representative
Monti no and representative Edgar name
whoa all right and uh chair Hill
yes so I see representative Edgar you
were a no no nay okay so that is
88 on the
amendment uh amendment is 88 um and
Amendment fails um that means we're back
to the original Bill we have a motion
for the original
bill
representative cost I don't I don't have
it on me but doesn't that um mean that
it's open to further amendments as well
and I do have an amendment but I don't
have it on on
me the original bill has a penalty I do
I have an amendment that just pulls the
penalty out I don't know if it's worth
doing I mean it we're we're pro reading
tea leaves we'll probably end up 8 on
everything anyway so we should just you
know
um Mr yes and in previous get me out of
this yeah I in previous presedent you
haven't uh typically taken an amendment
there was a previous bill that had a
last and and just as a reminder you
didn't that is that is My Prerogative um
to take an amendment or not um I guess
what I
will say or I will toss out to the
committee is um rather
than my understanding is this amendment
hasn't been
drafted no it it's been drafted yeah
it's been drafted I just don't I didn't
think you don't physically have it you
have the number I don't physically have
it I probably can find the number but
I'm saying if it's not going to well
that's any the outcome of this then I
don't really want to go through those
motions does that make um
would that make any difference if the
penalty phase which is what it's being
purported the the amendment would do if
the penalty phased because otherwise I'm
not going to waste additional time and
or take time away from here um that we
wait to have it copied and drafted if
it's not going to do anything then I
would ignore that
Amendment
so is there um I can do this
by by um raising of hands um if that
makes any difference um and why don't I
why don't I do it in that form so if if
an amendment was put forth that um
eliminated the penalty phase of the
original bill um who would want that
that amendment to have in front of
them who who would want that Amendment
here
yeah no probably not the same way um if
if the amendment did um took away the
penalty phase um would you what's that
would you be inor would you be in favor
of the bill um raise your
hand I I'm not Mr chair I'm sorry I just
think in the same way of hypotheticals
it's really I'm hesitant to raise my
hand in such a hypothetical it but all
it all it's purporting to do is remove
that part portion and is it worth us to
bring that Amendment
here I'm not seeing huge numbers of
hands so I'm going to ignore that
amendment that it exists um and so we're
back at this um unamended House Bill
and I am looking for a
motion representative Sheen I move off
to pass representative Sheen moves off
to pass is there a second seconded by
representative mcarter further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role ought to pass on
House Bill
1479 on the motion of a to pass for
1479 repan yes rep costable
yes Clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative
mcarter yes representative ner yes
representative sers yes representative
wall that was a no I got it
representative nutting Wong no
Representative turot no representative
Richards no representative McGee no
Representative mameo no representative
Montiel no representative Edgar
nay and chair Hill uh
yes 88
88 um motion about to pass fails uh
further
motions representative nting Wong I mov
to itl uh in expedient to
legislate representative nning Wong
moves inexpedient to
legislate is there a second second
by okay do that if you want sure
um further
discussion seeing none I'm going to take
one
minute
actually I'm going to take five minutes
um
Republicans
okay that was mostly for making sure our
paperwork is right here um we are we
have a motion on the floor that's been
uh of itl it has been seconded um
further discussion seeing none um I'll
ask the clerk to call the rooll thank
you Mr clerk uh Mr chair um okay on the
motion of itl for HB
1479 representative Shen
no Representative costable no the clerk
votes no representative Pearson no
Representative mcarter no representative
ner no Representative sers no
representative
wall representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Richards yes representative McGee yes
representative mamillo yes
representative Edgar I oh I'm sorry Miss
Monte representative montio skipped over
you
yes and the chair
no no that is 88 surprise okay we've
exhausted it all um so that means uh we
would need to have no recommendation
going to the floor and the motion I'm
assuming on the on this on your side is
going to be
itl it will okay sorry yes and who will
write representative nutting
Wong um all right and we we're all set
we've done everything on House Bill 1479
we can do at the
moment just give us a minute to reset
and then we'll be moving on
to um 1080 House Bill
Amendment coming around for
all right I'll open the exact session on
House Bill
1080 recognize representative shien for
a motion yes I move a to pass
representative Sheen moves out to pass
is there second seconded by
representative Wong
sorry uh nothing Wong sorry
um representative sheim would you like
to speak to your motion
uh I'd like to move an amendment
representative Sheen adds an amendment
amendment number uh amendment number
204-9416 so uh allege admin um set up a
subcommittee to um work on this bill um
rep nutting Wong was on the subcommittee
re Hobson was on the subcommittee with
me um we had members of the legislative
youth advisory Council there we had um
representative Valerie McDonald um
representative Jonah wheer was with us
um as well as the prime sponsor of the
bill representative Jody Nelson and we
had a a good 2hour conversation talking
about the council uh what it's currently
doing um Visions what we'd like to see
it
become and so uh we took the ideas oh
I'm sorry representative Tierney was
also he's not here today um was also in
that subcommittee meeting um so we um
wrote an amendment that basically um
takes all of the ideas that we talked
about in that sub committee um and
drafted an amendment um the amendment uh
to the bill defines the charge of the
council and it sets a a clear Focus for
the
council it lowered the number of Youth
appointments and it gave all the youth
appointments um solely to the speaker of
the house so it's the appointments don't
have to be spread out between the
Secretary of State's office the
governor's office and the pr Senate um
Senate office um it also set up uh
legislative co-chairs and a legislative
um advisor um that's where uh help from
Rhett McDonald and Rhett wheeler came in
um because we um wrote the amendment
saying that um these co-chairs would be
the youngest member of the majority
party and the youngest member of the
minority party or their design because
you know we don't know who the youngest
member will be next term um as well as
uh a more seasoned legislator um
advisor um we
um there was an issue um currently in
law uh with postsecondary students we
there's a current member that's actually
not following current law because she's
taking um postsecondary education
classes outside of the state uh online
so we we changed that that postsecondary
students have to be residents of New
Hampshire but they're allowed to be
taking postsecondary education anywhere
um um we um added that appointments
shall be at a minimum from all 10
counties in New Hampshire so we have a a
wide Regional
reach um we also um made an amendment
that makes youth terms uh we have a
one-year term and a 2ear term for youth
members half of the members will have
serve a one-year term and half will
serve a 2-year term and we did that so
we have fresh members coming in every
term it's not the same membership so um
it gives more opportunity for youths
around the state to participate and we
also did this um to have um some members
serve two years so we have some um
experience on the council so it's not
all new people coming in and kind of
trying to figure out what what to do um
we also add a requirement um for the the
youth to read the oath of office and the
Constitution New Hampshire Constitution
and the US
Constitution and um I I really like this
part of the amendment because to be
honest coming into this I never really
had much knowledge about what this
Council does and I've really enjoyed
learning about it and um looking at
other councils around the the country
and um we added an amend added a part of
this amendment to um put a legislative
youth advisory Council page on the
general court website dedicated to the
council um we um also came up with an
idea um to make a you know what makes a
good lak candidate document so when
we're promoting this Council um we'll
have a document that um um States you
know what makes a good candidate and
also um we um put in the amendment that
the Department of Education will promote
lak whenever
possible and um I think that we all feel
um that this is a a good Amendment and I
think that um that it's it's really
going to help the council and hopefully
um get the word out um to other youth
uh what we're doing here and and open
that up uh to more youth that would like
to
participate thank you very much
um further discussion about the
amendment I just represent Richards
thank you Mr chair I just want to just
on lines three and four um which are
talking about like reappointment with
the one and twoe terms which I think is
a really cool idea and and support but
just in terms of
clarification and to meet the need of
having the folks be on for a while and
the the that um benefit to the council
um there is a line um
that I just wanted to get clear about so
if someone serves a one-year term can
they then also be appointed for a
two-year term or can they
not um if there are openings they could
be re reappointed for another
year then so they would be reappointed
for one more year effectively serving a
total of two yes okay thanks I
think um I think that is done in the
initial um right now there are there are
some members that have been there longer
than others or um existing
members um I think and correct me if I'm
wrong but it would I think what they're
trying to do is make sure that those
that have just served or are currently
um
serving they would only be eligible for
a one-year term going forward so they
may have three years but in future years
it would uh all all councils yeah would
only be doing it's it's a way of I think
of offsetting so that you're constantly
having experience but new members at the
same
time further questions discussion
representative
hubson thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to say that I enjoyed working on the uh
subcommittee as well and um I think that
we established some really good guard
rails um I felt like it the the mission
was very Broad and uh I I just think
that the the kids are really excited
about it I could tell that and um I look
forward to seeing what they come up with
in the future so thank you for letting
me have the opportunity and chair Sheen
did a great
job fur further
discussion representative nting wall
just that I
agree short but eloquent uh
representative Pearson um I was asked
to give a statement for my colleague
from Derry who who could not be here so
representative Nelson um would like to
thank the committee for all the work the
subcommittee
and she is um in favor of the amendment
that's brought
forward thank you representative Pearson
further discussion representative wall
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate all
the work that the subcommittee put into
all of this and I appreciate the work
that you've come out with of really good
Amendment and made a good bill better
thank
you thank you representative wall
further
discussion one more representative
hubson just one more real quick thank
you uh I wanted to thank uh
representative Nelson for all the work
that she did and uh it was a fair amount
of corralling so she she did an amazing
job too so I just wanted to put that out
there thank you great um seeing no other
further discussion
um are we ready to adopt the amendment
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
H I'll ask the clerk I'll ask the clerk
to call the
rooll I will ask the clerk to call the
role all righty thank you Mr Mr chair uh
for amendment
0944 to
hb180 um representative Vice chair Sheen
yes representative costable representa
oh clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative mcarter yes
representative nder yes representative
sers yes representative wall yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Richards yes representative McGee yes
yes representative mamila yes
representative
Montiel yes representative Edgar I and
Mr chair yes okay so 16
unanimous now we have ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
1080 any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call a roll than thank you Mr
chair on ought to pass as amended
hb180 representative Sheen yes
representative costable clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative n yes representative
cellers yes representative wall yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot yes representative
Richards yes representative McGee yes
representative mamillo yes
representative Monti
yes and representative Edgar I and
chairman Hill
yes
okay it's unanimous 16 do I hear consent
you
do thought I might um without objection
um House Bill 1080 will be on
consent hold on just a second for us
to recommit
ourselves the final bill um post Bill
1388 388 just a
minute
there ready you good
yep all right I'll open up the um
executive session on House Bill 1388
recognize representative for a
motion I move out to pass representative
wall moves out to pass uh is there a
second seconded by representative
mcarter um Bill's open to further
Amendment
comments I think there is just comments
that's all
um I have an amendment representative
Sheen um yeah I move you offer an
amendment yeah I um offer amendment
number
0693 I don't have it either thank
you representative Sheen offers
Amendment
0693 this is from our
last meeting if you still have it if you
don't
um we can
probably take a minute
and put them together there were two
amendments that were given um this is
this is um the only one we will be
bringing up today which is uh
0693 H I don't have I don't think
well okay I have a card copy that
doesn't look like a hard
copy did you want to did you want to
talk on this one or on the amendment or
not okay I just don't this is the one
that Chang
C
okay
okay we're back um so everyone should
have
2024 6
0693 h um amendment to house bill
correct this is what will
euphemistically call the Bob Linn
Amendment um which means that it's uh
coming from the Ethics Committee
um this is uh
everything uh for those people that are
new to legislative Administration this
has been this is the third year year of
virtually the same bill um and this is
the
final outcome of the language that the
Ethics Committee has requested us to put
forth um it still includes the special
interest which has been a bone of
contention in the past um and it does
include the um exception for uh when it
when or the defining line for when a um
a board legislator or a household member
serves as an officer board member of
more than 1% of the outstanding
Securities of the corporation those were
the two items that were in Conflict
right to the end um and and um this is
the adoption of the ethics committee's
language um
are there
questions and again this is what you had
the last meeting we just wanted to make
sure we had a couple of questions on
some of the language and whether the
amendment was actually drafted correctly
but um it was so um you've had you've
had this since the last meeting this is
not anything that's different
today
any comments yeah representative W thank
you and I want to thank you thank
representative Shen for coming forward
with this amendment this is an issue
which the Ethics Committee has struggled
with for years and years and years and
it's been so difficult to come up with
something that's really clear and very
concise um this clearly tells us what a
special interest is and what we shall
and shall not do regarding that the same
with the financial interest this
clarifies a whole lot of issues that
we've had over the years with members
either thinking they should
recuse or not people recusing when they
haven't needed to people not recusing
when they should um this is excellent I
thank you thank you representative wall
um it makes my heart sing to hear that
uh
again it's been three years uh that
we've worked on this um further
discussion seeing none um I will ask the
clerk to call the role on the
amendment
2024 06
93h okay on Amendment 06
93h um Vice chair Shen yes
representative
costable clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative mcarter yes
representative nder yes representative
sers yes representative wall yes
representative nutting Wong yes
representative turot
yes uh representative Richards yes rep
representative mgee yes representative
mamila yes representative montio yes and
Mr chair
yes 16 hello
oh Mr Edgar oh I'm sorry okay rep
Edgar
hi hello hello sorry about that not
treating our guests very well are we
trying I'm trying okay
unanimous okay uh what does that mean
for number unanimous what 50
16 uh vote being 16 to nothing uh
Amendment um
0693 passes uh we now have a to pass as
amended any further
discussion representative Pearson I have
a I have a question for representative
wall being on the Ethics
Committee if representative wall would
like to take your question that's fine
well because it's right because
everything passes through the chair well
the they I don't know why it would be
scary um but the the question that I
have is is that if this does go through
the process and makes it into law with a
change of current condition is the
Ethics Committee
prepared for a workload that's going to
come from this initially because there's
going to be questions of clarity that I
think are going to need to come from
this I mean I know you necessarily
aren't speaking for the whole committee
but just a personal opinion I'm the the
Ethics Committee from time to time does
have quite a workload but my opinion on
this is I think I I shouldn't speak for
the Ethics Committee as a whole but I
believe there's going to be some relief
thank
you I I'm going to jump in a bit um I
think in some ways there will be um an
adjustment to this but I but I actually
think in the long run the Ethics
Committee this will relieve some of
their work rather than add to it um I
think I think you're correct that there
may
be
um new new phraseology new something new
guard rails new guard rails but I think
um I think they are they've been
chomping at the bit for having this um
and I think they understand um there's
some experience on the Ethics Committee
I have a feeling that they know what
they're getting
into thank
you further
discussion representative W okay uh
thank you I was just reading a note that
was passed to me thank you um I I think
it would always be helpful for us to
have some continuing education so that
the members are aware of changes that
are being made and I will make that
recommendation thank
you
any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to caller roll uh to pass as
amended on
[Music]
6938 on
hb180 no oh my
gosh this is why we do this
1388 no we're good take your time okay
I'm
good on HB
1388 yes representative
shien yes representative costable yes
clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative trany oh I'm sorry n yes
I'm going off my old sheet that's why
representative sers yes representative
wall yes representative nutting Wong
yes representative turot yes
representative Richards yes
representative McGee yes representative
mamea yes representative
Monti yes and representative
Edgar I and chair Hill yes okay so
that's
16 unanimous the vote being 16 to
nothing on um House Bill 1388 as amended
do I hear consent consent
consent I thought I might um without
objection seeing
none we have an Ethics bill on
consent holy
moly um I'm going to close the hearing
on or the exact session on House Bill
1388 well that that wraps up our um are
work for this half of the term um or
this year so I have not seen any bills
coming to us from I but I don't know
where they're coming from anyway um I
haven't seen there may be an Ethics Bill
coming to us from the other side um of
the wall so uh don't put away your
ethics hat yet um other than that I
haven't seen anything or heard anything
uh we're all set for tomorrow apparently
um so we have one or two bills on uh on
the regular calendar for tomorrow
and I'm all set anybody have any other
questions concerns comments yes
representa wall thank you uh I just
wanted to thank you as our chairman for
handling some tough issues
beautifully and I appreciate your
leadership I appreciate everyone who's
worked on the committee it's been an
excellent committee to with which to
work that um you know we're free to say
what we believe in and what we don't um
there's been open discussion no
animosity it's been a good working
relationship thank you thank you um I
want to take a minute quickly and thank
our um our helpers for today our uh our
we couldn't do the work without you
thank you very much for taking the time
off um and and appreciate your
input um that's you too
um I'm good thanks very much have a good
day thank
you